place de l'inviter unique la bible et
qui vous propose un tour d'horizon en
compact spécialiste local et autour de
la table pour nous éclairer la mienne au
genre bonjour d'être maître de
conférences en sciences politiques à
l'université de la réunion
ces femmes fontaines bonjour bonjour
vous êtes français au quotidien
spécialisé en politique et au téléphone
avec noah un sudiste geoffroy grosjean
jour communicants et vous avez participé
à la vie politique locale à différents
niveaux
lundi politique qui est une émission que
vous pouvez suivre en vidéo sur le site
intéresse la première niche à laquelle
vous pouvez également participer si vous
avez des questions à poser à nos invités
ici vous nous appelez 02 62 99
merci d'avoir accepté de venir donc
débattre jusqu'à 13h pour aider nos
histoires mieux comprendre comment se
présente cette cette campagne électorale
c'est vous qui seriez ce matin dans le
quotidien et municipales premier vote
après la colère quand on voit la volonté
des sortants se représentent et qu'on
trouve un sondage réalisé par s'agisse
pour obliger la première que 38% des
électeurs qui souhaitent voter sans
crainte est pour l'heure mais actuelle
rien n'a changé que tout va se
représenter comme comme les autres
scrutins avant lui le détail de ce
savoir comment vous qualifieriez cette
élection commence que vous la voyez ils
sont selon vous les les traits marquants
de cette compétition va commencer je
commençais v on est bon enfant assez
loin de séance un monde et à six mois
quand même mettre en place d'ici là où
changer mais on est parti pour avoir une
grande quantité de merde que nous c'est
ce qu'ont vécu ce matin un quotidien qui
se représente en tout cas qui pour le
moment n'ont jamais dit
qu'il ne le ferait pas et beaucoup
d'anciens maires aussi qu'il va leur
revenir
comment comment peut s'incarner le rejet
qu'on a perçu en fin d'année des des
élus c'est s'est uni une des questions
on pense pas interroger les des mers
forcément on verra ça peut-être un peu
plus abstention des voitures des
nouvelles listes qui se constituerait un
mais cette faculté après c'est pas
monter ces listes des chocolats ce que
vous voyez vous cette sept combats
qu'elle aurait d'un chien sera de voir
comment sont le tas parce que le scrutin
européen est un scrutin de liste de
niveau national là on va voir sur le
terrain local
comment on peut se traduire le mouvement
de gilet jaune et est ce qu'il va
trouver un débouché politique
une des difficultés de ce mouvement
c'est qu'il n'a jamais vraiment trouvé
de traduction politique donc là est ce
que le terrain municipal va lui
permettre de reprendre les positions en
tout cas est ce que ça va influencer le
vote
voilà ça c'est déjà un premier enjeu le
deuxième enjeu c'est clairement alors
peut-être - la réunion ça paraît mal
engagée en tout cas pour pour le parti
présidentiel mais ça va être pour elle
et rem de réussir son implantation
locale se sait pour le moment un parti
hors sol on est trop paul comme ici ici
il me semble que c'est très mal parti
mais il faut préjuger de rien sachant
combien les alliances le jeu des
alliances et des positionnements
localement est très instable et très
dépendants des conjonctures du monde
huawei revenir geoffroy géraud quoi ce
que vous enfermez vous cette campagne 1
écoutez comme dans toute configuration
il ya deux hypothèses
qui sont pas forcément d'ailleurs a
opposées celle du changement dirais
c'est la continuité dire a priori on
peut se dire que il ya quelque chose qui
va disparaître lors de ce scrutin est ce
quelque chose c'est un univers politique
existe depuis 40 ans 1 c'est à dire de
d'acteurs politiques de formation
politique qui ont été façonnés par le
jeu politique
debré contre vergès autonomie condé par
antalis et c'est qui ce sont des acteurs
politiques des sensations ptx ans encore
en place
il est probable que certains vont
demeurer d'autres il est probable vont
disparaître et je prends pas prendre de
risque en disant que par exemple à saint
benoît on va connaître à fin d'une
époque en pas un grand risque en disant
ça d'autres enjeux j'en vois un grand
compte reconnaissant la réunion c'est
savoir qui va in fine et advenir du
parti communiste réunionnais dire est-ce
qu'il va conserver sa seule commune qui
par le jeu des alliances il va non
seulement préservé sa commune mais en
plus accéder aux responsabilités dans
d'autres communes
est-ce qu'il va peut-être allons
reconquérir on ne fait pas ces prix de
de la guerre des droites à la réunion
qui devait être une guerre des droites
qui paie depuis la fin de l'été money et
de michel debré voilà donc pas de parler
d'un jeu de pas mal de pistes pour pour
débattre de 2,7 de ce scrutin
on sait vous dit d'autres discussions se
passent les scrutins locaux
configuration malgré ce que lors des
derniers scrutins nationaux bien que le
vôtre contesté dans toutes les communes
lors dès lors des européennes jean-luc
mélenchon et marine le pen en tête au
premier tour de la présidentielle il ya
deux ans que est ce que cette
protestation malgré tout va se peut se
traduire dans dans ce scrutin la
danseuse que d'amis si pâle ou est-ce
que c'est forcément deux choses
complètement séparé moi je pense que
c'est difficile sur le maïs mal
puisqu'il faut faut pas revenir quand
même a déjà identifié une locomotive à
une tête de liste à constituer une liste
ce qui représente plusieurs dizaines de
personnes qui seraient motivés pour
venir qui partagent aussi des
orientations communes
c'est toute la difficulté pour les gens
qui veulent du changement ces deux
d'avoir les moyens de s'engager de sens
et le il ya aussi la capacité des îles
uac tuer la récupérer sur le terrain
local ccl voix contestataires très
clairement l'observent dans des communes
comme saint-andré ou comme le tampon où
le voir une disjonction mais qui n'est
pas une telle disjonction entre les
scrutins nationaux et les scrutins
locaux
il ya tout un tas de thématiques qui
permet
aux élus locaux de récupérer et de
capitaliser une souris en partie sur ce
mécontentement est ce qui a amené des
candidats qui pourraient être tentés de
récupérer les thèmes portés par le passé
il y à un certain nombre de choses
autour de la préférence locale par
exemple qui résonne tout à fait bien
avec eux ce que défend le four nationale
autour de la préférence nationale est
d'être localisé très dans le localisme
dans l'enracinement de ces mêmes se
situe point de vue idéologique ça
devient même récurrents la réunion c'est
plutôt inquiétant
et pourtant jean legros les tentatives
jusqu'à maintenant d'implantation du
rassemblement de l'ex pensionnaire
nouveau construire c'est très paradoxal
comme vous le savez le premier député
front national de l'histoire c'est à
dire avant que le fn n'entre à
l'assemblée en 86 à la faveur de deux
inscrits à la proportionnelle le premier
député fn était un réunionnais c'était
le député-maire de saint-louis
jean fontaine qui étaient des fumeurs de
saint louis qui n'était que député qu'il
avait perdu la commune de saint louis
moi je l' ai souvent dit à votre antenne
gelé beaucoup écrit c'est toujours pensé
étant moi même issu des amis d'allemands
de cette histoire dual gauche contre
droite que la gauche droite réunionnaise
était souvent une droite dure droite
nationaliste une droite qui avait eu
longtemps ces accords avec l'action
française on tient un héros si vous
voulez par contre il yaa et je pense que
monsieur des chantiers fils de l'homme
voit très bien de quoi je parle
il n'ya pas d'appareil un pari faire
grand mot mais en rendant dans la
réalité un appareil c'est celui qui dans
la famille à peine physiquement mené
gens voter parce que voter c'est pas
naturel pour tous côtés c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on fait qui va de soi
au contraire beaucoup de gens n'ont pas
de respect à participation politique et
plus il n'y a pas de figure
charismatique du franc n'a aucun front
national à la réunion et qui a pas
l'appareil front national je pense qu'il
y aura pas vraiment d'incidence est
d'ailleurs notre ascension en 2d que
pour l'instant j'ai jamais vu de la part
de marine le pen qui pourtant a des
accointances ici poussé à des
fréquentations ici qui de longue date je
n'ai jamais vu à part du front national
de marine le pen de son père la volonté
de mettre en place ici le même appareil
les fans ne veulent pas une raison que
j'ignore et signe à mayotte qui sera
encore plus favorable oui c'est parce
que dix jours froids mais on a aussi
observé concernant les appareils du fn
c'est les figures de cesse de changer
c'est à dire ils ont du mal à rester
dans le temps à s'installer
est ce que ceci dit ça c'est une
difficulté à expliquer parce ce lien
potentiel électoral il n'a jamais été
exporté donc il ya effectivement un
mystère en de ce côté là qui est
peut-être aussi à chercher sur le fait
que les thèmes identitaires le front
national n'a pas été les seuls à les
préempter et d'un point de vue plus
général si on regarde l'histoire c'est
quelque chose qui n'a cessé de circuler
entre eux une extrême et l'autre de
l'échiquier politique la réunion je
pense à l' aventure politique de rené
payet dans les années 30 qui a contribué
de manière très forte à l'analyse à sion
politique à la réunion à reconstruire
les formes de la mobilisation politique
à la réunion où ça s'est joué
constamment soins d'un très ambigu qui
est tout rôle à la fois des ligues
nationalistes et d'extrême droite mais
qui le pouvaient aussi l'entrée en
complicité avec le ce qui allait devenir
le la base du futur p serre et entre les
deux formations en tout cas entre cet
élu est là le pcr il ya eu une forme de
la foi de repoussoir mais aussi de
compagnonnage dans les années 50 et 60
donc quelque chose de très ambigu qui
fait que peut-être le front national en
30 elle n'a pas pu
prospérer est ce que c'est un autre une
dose de partis de l'échiquier politique
la france soumise ici qu'il ya un élu
jean graton peut réussir sans son
implantation en c1 et les députés qu'il
parlement ce qui va ce qui va être
candidat pour les élections municipales
est ce que est ce que là il ya une
interrogation possible
est ce que je vais dire sur les cendres
du pcr et leurs phrases disent vrai il
en a 2 20 si les députés européens
tassé lors oui mais mais localement
disons des listes en tout cas le front
national endroit aussi sans doute mais
la force a soumises à des listes dans
certaines communes à saint-leu à à à
bras panon
aussi je pense que kaki qui le font mais
oui effectivement l'époque capitaliser
sur le l'énorme potentiel électoral
qu'ils ont exprimée dans de précédentes
élections ne vous fera pas je pensais
avoir un nom surtout je vends des
députés contre un maire qui dans son
temps n'est pas aidé par quatre en dire
plus 9e passe ou pas son année par
l'accroissement garder ses amis de la
terre ferme
c'est une petite commune a donc le poids
d'un député au charismatique d'un député
ripper dit que c'est pas rien
après rien n'est joué cela dit chaque pc
on fait quand même un appareil est
peut-être un simple qu'on peut aimer
recettes 8% fait que plr est quand même
bien implanté le fait partie du vélo
oui oui pardonnez moi est le fait
surtout que france a soumis ce soit
contrainte elle même à nous organiser en
disant aux organes de son gaz
en fait on explique on inclut à la tête
du client
comment ça marche le vois pas comment on
organise une discipline sur des bassins
pas on aura des militants dévoués qui
vont une organisation à l'échelle d'un
département d'une région accueillera
délit de conquête du pouvoir
je te jure pour nuancer je comptais
chargement l'analyse de geoffroy mais
peut-être qu'on en sait dire que la
france insoumise le bénéfice d'un leader
de fait puisqu'il ya un député qui lui
lierait qui laboure le terrain il ya un
certain nombre de militants et de
militants qui sont prêts aujourd'hui à
monter aux élections municipales à se
mobiliser posées sont ici pâle
aucun des enjeux pour la france un sou
liste peut-être réussi à transformer
l'essai de l'élection législative en
essayant de s'implanter les plus
fortement sur le terrain municipal
pas forcément en obtenant la conquête de
ville souffre peut-être bras panon qui
part effectivement jouable pour la
france insoumise
en tout cas en étant capable de peser
dans l'entre-deux tours et en devenant
une composante importante des futures
majorités de gauche qui pourrait se
construire en particulier dans l'ouest
dans les souvenirs de la république
l'oci et doit s'il s'implanter
localement comme la force à soubise où
le rassemblement national
c'est compliqué en même temps on sent
bien qu'il ya un certain nombre de
personnalités politiques qui se disent
trop compatibles
quand ils sont en tout cas est ce que ça
va être par par l'ogc et de ces
personnalités à col st classique
c'est un cas de figure qu'on retrouve
tout au long de la troisième république
où les députés
grosso modo il se colle à la majorité
parlementaire dominante et donc pour une
la département ou une région
ultrapériphérique effectivement d'être
en cours auprès de la majorité en place
olivo la métropole c'est un enjeu
essentiel mais c'est pas forcément dont
que c'est aussi ce qui explique ce jeu
pas de deux entre le entre l'elysée le
président de région et c'est ce que
c'est à la fois qu'on promet tant
localement que de se rapprocher des
manuels macron mais du point de vue de
la stratégie d'un président de région
d'un même d'un président de département
pour faire avancer ces dossiers
ça reste vitale donc il n'y a rien qui
s'oppose en principe un rapprochement
possible d'autant que lille et les
options politiques idéologiques sont
relativement proches mais le contexte
électoral et le conte ambiance politique
actuelle ne le permettent pas est-ce que
s'adresse la république que en marche
d'après ce que vous percevez du terrain
est ce que est ce que ça peut prendre
tank de 2,2 de vote local est ce que ce
que les
est ce que les dirigeants localement
rare il va s'implanter à pourcy fait des
listes compliqué c'est compliqué puisque
on sait toujours pas ce qu'ils font aux
élections localement quand on voit
l'état des sondages vous dit que aller à
l'élection
4une si besoin d'être non je ne vois pas
je vois à moins qu'ils le disent entre
sur des lieux dans les conseils sur des
listes un peu comme ils l'ont fait
jusqu'à présent un peu un permis souk à
ces listes on sait que le on sait que
par ailleurs a besoin dans un arbre puis
un peu plus loin 6e par des conseillers
municipaux qui vont pas de liste alors
les alliances comme ça pour pouvoir
avoir des racines trois ans une chance
cela dit que le maire actuel qui est qui
et qui n'échappe voilà qui est le drame
son fils à sa succession et croire loin
un duel bien connu est-ce que sur les
deux derniers points sur les scrutins
nationaux et leur antre locaux
le fait que l'écologie des écologistes
ont fait un bon score aux européennes
sont reviennent un petit peu est-ce que
ici en a qui peuvent essayer de se
refaire un peu la suppression est ce que
ça peut jouer en scrutant missionne oui
[Musique]
plus dans des logiques alliance
le voir elle émergentes candidat
écologiste en catégorie pardon pas
directement des appareils des facilités
que je vais passer ou signifie que les
échanges et les écologistes difficultés
récurrentes à s'organiser a duré son le
plan national comme sont le plan local
on a souvent dénoncé où on se soit moqué
de l'hospice chapelle et leur sectarisme
et leur capacité à autodétruire
d'excellents résultats électoraux à
l'occasion donc rien n'est acquis de ce
côté là et sur le plan local ils
souffrent eux aussi d'une certaine
faiblesse d'implantation il manque de
cadres très clairement et d'une
structure politique forte et tant qu'ils
ne l'auront pas sain difficile pour eux
d'émerger comme force centrale d'une
alliance politique force d'appoint
possible après moi je vois une exception
mais ce qu'est la partie encore au
mouvement écologiste et vanessa
miranville les qui capitalise elle si
elle est réélue d'abord sur son mandat
et sur la capacité qu'elle a eu à
s'implanter dans sa commune ses
anciennes couleurs
aujourd'hui et qui sont d'âge pour la
première une cote de popularité des
réunionnais miranville les écologistes
on sent très encouragé un cas à part
les résultats aux européennes et il
envisage même à saint denis où ils sont
pourtant dans une majorité en alliance
de présenter des listes seules et ça
marche parce qu'ils ont quand même
quelque chose d'aussi à construire
retourner des carrières et l'opposition
au gardien dans les trois communes qui
sont concernés d'autres nous allons voir
ailleurs s'il ya des projets avec
l'étiquette d'un parti politique y est
presque tout cela va arriver
mon et en sang a indiqué ça veut dire
quoi que les clivages idéologiques dont
on a parlé qui ont prévalu ces dernières
décennies si c'est fini il y en a plus
ou est ce que finalement ça c'est juste
une scène de broadway ce que la
personnalisation complète des
candidatures endroits où la situation
est confuse par exemple atteint le plier
ou ce qu'il a à dire
à saint pierre est clair par exemple
enfin les yeux si c'est clair saint
denis c'est vrai que c'est un peu
compliqué alors sans doute attendre et
jean paul virapoullé dudit candidat
c'est jean-marie vraiment en fin d'année
dans l'est dans les hameaux ce que j'ai
pu rencontrer et interviewer tous
gardent bien
dire qu'ils sont vraiment de gauche est
donc évident moi je suis d'abord pour
l'île soit disant il a il a enterré le
vieux monde j'en suis pas persuadé parce
que l'on retrouve en fait les clivages
droite gauche y compris la cendre de la
république sans doute de ce côté là un
appel d'air et un besoin de
renouvellement
donc les clivages qui structure le
paysage politique français vont
persister vont peut-être se recomposer à
la faveur de nouveaux enjeux autour des
questions climatiques
un exemple aussi autour de la question
de fracture territoriale puisque c'est à
l'inde est l'un des éléments qui ont
contribué à la mobilisation des gilet
jaune de france qui se font un peu face
ou qui s'ignorent ou qui se tournent le
dos je sais pas trop comment on le le
analysé en détail mais en tout cas voilà
il ya ces clivages nouveau qui
apparaissent dans le débat et que les
partis traditionnels ne prenait pas
forcément en charge passe et les
clivages apparent les structures en tout
cas du débat dont il va y avoir aux
distributions mais penser qu'on est
au-delà de tout franc de l'appartenance
politique il y aura pas besoin de ses
tics t politiquement pour s'identifier
auprès des électeurs ça enlève de
l'illusion avec de façon importante
vous avez laissé de permutation des
rolls et inattendue bon il ya deux droit
qu'à la réunion de droite il plutôt dur
la suite libéral la droite plutôt dur
était quand même incarnée par didier
robert qui a construit son pouvoir
régional banda sur l'ampli communiste je
suis rhétorique assez radicale de ce
point de vue là et maintenant et la
république en marche avec celle son
thème qui est le patron des républicains
la réunion incarne lui alors vraiment
dans les confrères incarne vraiment
plutôt la droite libérale sans trop
gaulliste sérieux l'identité qui n'aide
pas non plus au repérage colis et sa
5ème temps que de toute façon pour être
candidat pour avoir finalement être
présent sur le terrain pour un
financement pour avoir l'appui d'un
parti et aussi preuve en est une
une carence la droite était unie sous
forme de la sorte a permis donc ses
appuis en 2015 là les premières
plateformes qui s'en tenait la route
c'est plutôt à gauche on sait en tout
cas pour samoa saint paul on aura sans
doute est interposé voilà le match
européen fontaine s'il ya des appels à
la réconciliation qui sont assez bons
formats que je passe en 1 2 de la
réaliser avant ce mois et un gaucho - le
mécano et en place puisque des priorités
en gros à ceux qui étaient les mieux
implantés les parties évitent de
s'affronter entre socialistes et verts
insoumis pour l'instant on entend sur la
scène à saint-prest avec huguette bello
ça peut s'étendre sur l'île ce qui a les
moyens de trouver qui est le bon
candidat
je pense que c'est bien avancé un peu de
vrai dans ce lille à saint pierre ils
sont dits d'accord au port
même si encore un petit conflit il ya un
gros la mettre le pca entre le pcr une
meilleure en place mais on s'y fait vite
on dit je pense que tout le monde s'est
mis un peu près d'accord ça dans
certains cas de saint-andré où ça ça
parait insoluble
i wish we en face à droite
irréconciliables ce conflit entre orange
et free qui a compliqué le lait l'apli
que le crâne d'appuyer depuis des mois
et moi c'est ça sera pas l'occasion la
de les réembaucher la vie des gens je
suis pas devin il ya je pense là une
dimension personnelle à ce conflit
il ya aussi la dimension idéologique
le choix d'un positionnement politique
que souligné geoffroy géraud la façon
dont chacun envisage l'avenir de là
réunion sans didier robert beaucoup plus
alençon un certain nombre de projets de
réforme constitutionnelle que michel
fontaine qui de ce côté-là reste sur une
ligne qui serait plus celle de michel
debré quelque part d'une ancrage la
réunion à la métropole qui est ok pour
la décentralisation mais sur un modèle
qui en fait commun à l'ensemble des
régions françaises sans exception
particulière je suis pas si sûr 2014 ya
pas vraiment plate forme de draps
puisqu'à l'époque que didier robert
soutient camatchy contre jean paul
virapoullé à cet arrêt par exemple la
plateforme et se constitue juste après
autour du renouvellement sur le
département et d'arrivée
est ce que cette élection pourrait être
l'occasion de voir émerger de jeunes
politiciens et politiciennes des jeunes
savent que les anciens vont pouvoir
rester en place voire revenir parmi les
jeunes via dei et à ceux qui les
sollicitent le renouvellement de leurs
mandats passés y sont pris le pouvoir il
ya six ans il se commence déjà à être
des élus expérimentés je pense olivier
barrot à vanessa miranville ou des
nouveaux jeunes qui sont pas vraiment
gros ils sont les héritiers
c'est le cas de jean marie virapoullé
donc au delà il ya peut-être patrick
celi à saint benoît qui se pose en
alternative mais qu'elle est jeune
expérience politique mais effectivement
qu'ils seraient là nouveaux entrants que
titulaire d'un exécutif municipal donc
là ça suppose enfin ça montre aussi
qu'on n'accède pas un poste de maire en
sortant de nulle part que ça suppose un
long travail le militantisme déjà
d'avoir essuyé les plâtres en tant que
conseiller municipal dans une
municipalité matin faut pas oublier
c'est kiffant il faut les moyens aussi
bien pour engager une campagne fois
disponible déjà sa foi un gros c'est
pour ça que la c1 messieurs dans un
instant mais sur / en parler des
nouveaux fonds voilà très rares places
les anciens je disais qu'ils qui veulent
rester ou revenir des taux qui ont été
maires qui ont été soit abattus soit
écartée pour des raisons justice et
visiblement fière d'avoir été écarté
jeudi ses pains c'est un souci c'est un
troll intérêts lui même après carlo
d'inégibilité
tu as des condamnations et pourtant les
jeunes alors
c'est il faut c'est fini il faut des il
faut des mecs n'ont jamais été très
longtemps
ces gens qui étaient sur l'europe 1,6
mais ça c'est un classique de l'analyse
politique et de sociologie c'est à dire
que les électeurs eux n'agissent pas
forcément en fonction des valeurs
morales qui les anime
plus exactement il peut y avoir un écart
énorme entre la façon dont nous exprimer
en mécontentement façon dont ils vont se
positionner politiquement et parce que
en fait dans l'expression de leur
mécontentement ne refait pas en réalité
les besoins qu'ils éprouvent et on peut
dénoncer la corruption des élus mais au
fond à partir du moment où l'élu
garantie par exemple un petit boulot
vous garantit un accès au logement etc
sur un mode qui est un mode amical
clientèle air pour vous il a fait le
boulot et donc c'est un jeune élu vous
parlez aussi d'autres artistes et de ses
intérimaires qui fait pas lâcher
sécurité
le hasard se sont trouvés sur le
fauteuil et fille qui soit aussi de
celui de politiques de lyon où il ya un
couteau entre ancien ministre de
l'intérieur rare qu'on oui gérard gérard
collomb et
l'homme qui l'a mis à sac et qui n'a
plus du tout sans aller aussi à suivre
souffrent il ne s'y passe aussi un
tremplin nécessaire pour 2021
départementales et régionales
ça n'a pas existé on devine bien sûr n'a
pas s'il brille un temps doux et là ils
ont qu'il calcule alors après on est
habitué pour moi je suis toujours
partisan de l'hypothèse de petits à
l'église il est ouvert france existe
alors on a l'habitude compter de la
manière suivante c'est-à-dire qui
remporte que la gamme s60 municipal
suite avoir de réservoir de voix ou
régionales
des fois c'est pas le cas en 2000 à la
droite a tenu toutes les communes sauf 3
et paul vergès a remporté écrasante les
texans trois ans après enfin c'était
deux élections de mi-mandat on peut
toujours trouver des raisons mais à mon
sens c'est surtout le moment où l'effort
sont présentes vont mesurer leurs poids
respectifs
et c'est peut-être ça qui va confie la
possibilité de futures alliances c'est
normal je prenais question d'un
candidature de dire parce que s'il se
présente et qui sera mac ça change
complètement la donne et restent en
suspens président de région qui tue
d'air quand même un pouvoir extrêmement
un grand pouvoir va économique
saleh que je quand même relativement
ouvert mon sens c'est vraiment une
question centrale
je suis même enfin personnellement je le
ferai et tonique votre votre post it les
exos sûr il y aura ce serait à saint
denis un qui serait aussi qu'il pourrait
être candidat mais aussi le saint paul à
plusieurs mois du moins
parce que situation s'est compliquée à
saint-paul tous les singles bien c'est
pas forcément très simple
moi je pose la question différemment
sexy ce camp là ne présente un didier
robert à saint denis qu'il présente sa
ouais ça c'est plus tout comme ça qu'ils
sont qu'il faut propos didier robert qui
ce qu'il peut faire que servir de
locomotive point la droite dionysienne
là on ne voit pas de candidat
véritablement identifié à en dehors de
nassimah dindar nassimah dindar et
sénatrice
par ailleurs un certain nombre
d'obstacles sa candidature et elle fait
pas l'unanimité très loin de là au sein
de la droite
alors que la candidature de didier
robert est susceptible de le rassembler
au moins sur saint denis
mais c'est un gros challenge et qui ment
aussi il descend dans l'arène et qu' il
perd ça fragilise la fin de son mandat
la région et ça compromet sa réélection
à la tête de l'exécutif régional
est ce que dans le même ordre d'idées la
cimade un art qui se présenteraient ça
serait pas forcément parié avec une vue
sur 2020 doit se décider à temps des
résultats de sondages me semble mais
tout en sachant que des deux enfin de ce
qu'ils ont déclaré c'est que c'était
soit ibrahim dindar qui est déjà sur le
terrain il allait soit si les sondages
étaient meilleurs ça serait la cimade a
dardé comportant pas du tout la même
position notamment vis-à-vis vue du
président de région
ces deux positions très différentes
ou c'est intéressant parce que les
maires sortants ne se mêlerait
succession qui qui arrange s'entendre et
à saint-benoît vous serviront monsieur
c'est un peu différent des autres tout
simplement fier l'ellure 83 800 règle
une période où il avait été maire
d'avancé télévente et aux opérations
parce qu'ils ont perdu la mairie en 2001
mais oui oui si c'est ouvert très
ouverte et on voit même que ça leur
majorité que ça se sache prendre la
succession comme souvent ah ça oui on va
revivre un individuel
si si et si les candidats se présentent
elles qui miseront tout cas l'intention
de le faire c'est un micro contre claude
hoarau on se souvient de l'épisode de
cas de viol enfin compliqué en train de
travailler ce qu'on peut revivre ça
parce que sinon c'est un peu après c'est
bon je m'interroge sur la fin que le
noir au pardon je crois je te laissera
rien fait souvent des offres innovantes
[Musique]
rouge et vert certes c'est à dire où les
verts vraiment cela dit c'est
sociologiquement quand même le même
électorat
à mon sens qu'ils allaient encore ce
qu'ils ont tous décidé les avoir si des
docteurs m'a laissé le maire en place 0
mais il a quand même pour lui un bilan
inattendue moi je vous dis connaissant
bien saint louis je pensais pas qu'il
soit possible et son utilisation vient
d'être retoqué ça oui mais oui on dirait
qu'à la mythologie de l'employer comme
il a devancé par entièrement certain que
ce fameux des questions employés
communaux cité permis toujours le vote
surtout dans une ville perclus d'impôts
comme ça où il ya aussi des gens qui
veulent voter pour autre chose mais pour
d'autres raisons
mais ça c'est vraiment la question on
verra c'est la consternation sur le pont
ses 24 ans peut-être un risque mais je
crois pas que deux matches à saint louis
va jouer autour de 1 milliard ou claude
hoarau
jean plus haut non non je ne crois pas
et puis claude hoarau a mis en avant à
comment il faut appeler ça un sondage 1
les visites
faisant l'état de 4000 votes en sa
faveur
il va falloir me retrouver dans l'urne
après d'autant qu'il y aura une
candidature du même camp avec yvan
dejean sur saint-louis fin c'est la même
famille politique et les appels de de la
paire du mouvement de claude hoarau a
voté pour benoît hamon par exemple
dernière élection présidentielle
alors on va dire que les scrutins sont
pas les mêmes mais on est très très loin
des niveaux envisagés par des défauts
évoqués lors de ce autres c'est
peut-être le fichier sans doute le même
chercher peut-être que la demande les
mêmes ceux qui n'ont pas d'idées vote
parce que tous à broc score stalinien
est-ce que ce que je réponds parle aussi
avec d'autres communes est ce que est ce
que est ce que la simple ça va être à
regarder de près ou quoi couvrir sa bo
retend de retrouver son siège de colbert
est ce qu'on va faire si bien
aujourd'hui d'avancer crise s'est pas
jouée d'avancé une commune qui est
partie compliquée du point de vue
sociologique sociologique me sociologie
électorale à saint paul c'est un
patchwork de quartier qui ont des
profils sociologiques et les profits les
taureaux très variées vous que réussir à
se faire élire à saint-paul 7 capable de
capter des oies qui sont
ça n'a rien d'évident d'agréger les mois
qui viennent d'horizons politiques
politique là c'est différent
après la deuxième difficulté c'est pour
la droite en tout cas c est ce qu elle
part divisée ou est-ce qu'elle part unie
le fait que alain bénard envisage
sérieusement de se représenter je du mal
à me représenter ce que peu ce qu'il
peut peser politiquement mais ça peut
contrarier
très clairement la campagne de joseph
sinimalé
je pense qu'il est candidat à sa
succession 6 et la famille ouvre à faire
des comparaisons
l'or en 2009 contre on va revoter être
un coach que la première élection
quand on a revoté à saint paul la
décision de cyrille melchior de se
maintenir alors qu'alain bénard était en
tête à droite au second tour
je rejoins commune est très phréatique
ce qui se passe quand on voir en surface
excusez moi je tends d'avoir un parti
politique on regarderait aujourd'hui
c'est à dire et je vous ferai on sait
qu'ils vont plus compliqué je reprends
je vous ai 30 août sans émission merci
beaucoup en train de participer on se
retrouvera bien sûr d'ici ce scrutin qui
se déroule dans six mois exactement au
jour pour jour
merci beaucoup à vous passer une trappe
merci au revoir 12h15 13 heures le club
de la presse sur la première on va
parler des élections européennes qui
font de la corse rien sauf une chose
qu'il faut pas croire qu'il y avait une
vraie tentative de conjonction entre 0
berre et dès qu'on soit pour ou contre
moi je vous dis je suis ni pour ni
contre le club de la presse tous les
mardis de 12h15 à 13h avec gueye le
dantec sur la première le 21 septembre
la réunion se mobilisent pour le walk
line up des journées de nettoyage
mondial de la planète qui se déroulera à
pierrefonds saint pierre et au phare de
sainte-suzanne réunion la première sera
au coeur de cette mobilisation hors du
commun de 9h à 12h et vous fera vivre
cet événement en direct
vous souhaitez nous rejoindre pour une
demi journée de nettoyage des sites
naturels dans un moment de convivialité
ce samedi 21 septembre
alors inscrivez vous vite sur explore la
réunion point com